russian airstrikes have hit two
children's hospitals in ukraine
officials say three people died
including a child when a series of
blasts hit a maternity hospital in the
besieged city of mariupol
russia denies the reports as fake news
and says ukrainian troops had taken over
the building but western allies say the
russian military is using weapons
indiscriminately in what ukraine is
calling a genocide a warning this report
contains some disturbing images
the smoldering ruins
not of a military installation but a
maternity hospital in mariopol
the direct hit from an apparent russian
airstrike
sent women in labor fleeing into the
cold
hundreds are reported injured
mario paul has been the target of
sustained bombing and shelling for days
mass graves have been dug for the dead
authorities have told people how to
dispose of dead family members
wrap the bodies tie the limbs and leave
them on the street
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky is
calling russia's attacks on civilians a
genocide
today we must be united in condemning
this war crime of russia
which reflects all the evil that the
occupiers have brought to our land
all of the destroyed cities and
everything they've done
the bombing of a maternity hospital is
conclusive evidence that what is
happening is a genocide of ukrainians
in sotomir russian bombs hit two more
hospitals
one of them another children's hospital
the city is nearly 150 kilometers west
of kiev and has come under increasing
fire just the night before another
civilian target was hit
come and see this
[Applause]
he won't need any fighter planes anymore
but we do we do
diplomatic negotiations are stepping up
but as russia perseveres with heavy
shelling
ukrainian civilians are paying a high
price
for vladimir putin's bloody war
[Music]
earlier i spoke to dw correspondent nick
connolly in kiev and asked him how the
news of the air strikes on those two
children's hospitals has been received
in the ukrainian capital
most people i've spoken to don't really
have anything can't don't find any words
because it is just so shocking i think
it is you know clear to people now that
this is all-out war this is definitely
not the special operation that vladimir
putin is trying to call it this is a
award of the kind that europe really
hasn't seen probably since the second
world war and people are expecting this
to get a lot bloodier and a lot more
dangerous for civilians in the days to
come we've had those failed attempts at
civilian corridors to get people out of
mariopol those have failed several times
the ukrainians say that the russians are
just not sticking to their side of the
bargain are not
keeping two temporary ceasefires to
allow civilians out of that city that
has been under siege now for days and is
without power without mobile phone
networks and increasingly low on food
i think the main message that people
ukrainians are taking out of this is
that you know they are going to keep on
demanding the west closes the skies
above ukraine creates a no-fly zone
because they say this is a situation
where this is not war as
according to the rules this is a war
that is going to cause huge civilian
casualties and basically this is
at europe's conscience if europe if the
west of the us allows russia to keep its
dominance in the skies we're going to
see more hospitals more children dying
at home in their schools in
hospitals and this is going to be
something we're going to see again and
again so there's more push from zalenski
from other ukrainian figures we've seen
ukrainians gathering petitions thousands
of people signing them they're going to
send those west in the hope that maybe
the west will think again and will risk
more direct confrontation with russia
and create that kind of no-fly zone that
could allow ukraine
a better chance of winning this war
because on the ground in kind of hat
ground fighting between units on the
ground the ukrainians are doing pretty
well the russians are having big
logistical issues so the ukrainian
feeling is if they have that
safety from above and if the russians
are not allowed to bomb cities but also
ukrainian military then they have a much
better chance of
keeping their country
that's dw correspondent nick connolly in
kiev
well despite frequent shelling of
populated areas by russia u.s military
officials say there's been little change
on the ground over the past 24 hours but
one area where russian troops may be
making progress is in the city of
michilaiv which has seen heavy fighting
mikalev is key to russia's bid to seize
control of ukraine's black sea coast the
city of almost half a million is located
near the city of odessa which is
ukraine's main port mikalev has come
under heavy bombardment from russian
artillery
well joining me from mikkelav in ukraine
is the regional governor vitaly kim
thank you for speaking to us at this
very difficult time let me begin by
asking if the city of mikalai is still
under ukrainian control
yeah the city of megalife is still under
our control
and
also we
moved forward
to the gerson and sigirovka
in terms of the basics of food water
heating what are conditions like for
people in the city right now
about food medicine and water is okay in
the city in a big cities in our region
you know small
in small cities not small cities
small villages
there are some problems but we are
making our logistics to provide them all
they need there is no catastrophe but we
need
some storage because we have only one
way to supply for now
one road for supply for canal
and do you have a sense do you have
accurate updates
where exactly are the russian forces
right now in relation to your city
yes i have
all that data about this but i won't
won't tell you about it but because they
are moving
and
this is secret information i won't get
it
understood how likely is it that russian
forces will end up occupying the city as
they have in haisan do you still
have hope that they can be stopped at
this point
there is
if you will be in nicolette you will
see by your own eyes that we are not
going to leave our city in any way
and the thing that we are going to
attack and to
renew our territory the enemy is very
exhausted um
he has no motivation he has no fuel we
need more power and more vehicles for
for attack that's all i think that this
is the turning point of this war i don't
believe they can move forward faster
anymore
after two weeks of being under the
stress of invasion what about the
mentality of your people how are they
holding up
our mentality is now
for 100 percent
ukrainian
any small village resists the occupant
we're going to
communicate with russian we do not
making no deals with them we don't like
them we want them to go home and
this is
the common common idea of our region and
of our country
aside from those who choose to to stay
and fight in terms of communication with
the russians part of that is organizing
uh safe passage out of the city for
civilians are efforts underway do they
continue are you getting civilians out
who need to get out of that city
yes we have three ways
a freeway free road
that civilian can move
out from our city or region and first of
all it's
women and children
for now
many many of uh
strong men they are moving
to the city to help us for the fighting
so we have
we're growing with our war power and we
are waiting and looking forward for
attack
vitali kim governor of ukraine's
michelade region thank you so much for
taking the time
thank you
okay time to take a look now at some of
the other developments in the conflict
and washington is warning of a potential
chemical or biological weapons attack by
russia in ukraine it comes after moscow
accused the u.s of supporting a
bio-weapons program in ukraine the biden
administration believes the accusation
could be an attempt by the kremlin to
justify such an attack
the u.s house of representatives has
approved a massive spending bill that
includes 13.6 billion dollars of aid to
ukraine and european allies the funds
will cover the cost of sending u.s
troops and weapons to eastern europe as
well as care for
west refugees president kamala harris is
in warsaw for talks with polish leaders
tensions are high after the united
states rejected a proposal from poland
to transfer mig-29 fighter jets to a u.s
air base and then deliver them on to
ukraine after concluding her visit to
poland harris will then head to romania
the united nations says around 2.2
million people have now fled ukraine
most of them are women and children
often leaving loved ones behind to fight
not knowing whether they'll see each
other again
the majority of the refugees are
arriving in poland dw's alexandra von
naman sent us this report from the
western border crossing of signie
one last embrace before they say goodbye
vadim has brought his family to the
polish border so they can leave the
country he will be heading back to the
front lines
it is because of the kids
no one wants to leave their home it's so
hard you can't explain it
it's hard
we don't know
it was so good to have them by my side
when you're together with your family
you feel better
now i'll be alone
but i know they'll be safe
[Music]
and that safety is just a few meters
away we are at the border checkpoint in
shahini the busiest border crossing
between ukraine and poland those who are
now here have been waiting for hours
just like natalya and her twins they
escaped the russian bombardments in
harkev in eastern ukraine
we've been through a lot you're sitting
in the hall or in the cellar with your
children while they're bombing the city
and you don't know
will a bomb drop now and that's it what
did we do to deserve that
natalia doesn't believe that the war
will be over soon many ukrainians seem
to think the same and so the lions at
the border are not getting any shorter
people on the move both inside and
outside the country in desperate need of
protection and support as russia's war
with ukraine continues an estimated 4
million people may flee the country
according to the united nations
hot tea and snacks for free distributed
by ukrainian and international
volunteers along the road to the border
this is where we meet nattella from kiev
she's traveling alone with her three
children
the children are suffering the most
because my husband had to stay in kiev
they cry my older son keeps asking will
we never ever see dad again then he
starts crying again
the u.n has called it the fastest
growing refugee crisis in europe since
world war ii this is what it looks like
in real life
the foreign ministers of russia and
ukraine are in turkey for their first
face-to-face talks since the invasion of
ukraine turkish foreign minister melvut
chavisoldo greeted his ukrainian
counterpart dimitro kuleba and russia's
foreign minister sergey lavrov on the
sidelines of the diplomacy forum in
antalya
solo says the aim is to pave the way for
a meeting between the leaders of russia
in ukraine host turkey is a nato member
but has close ties to both countries
let's get more on this from dw's
political analyst for eastern europe and
russia constantine egert welcome to
constantine what can be expected from
the meeting today
hello anthony the decision essentially
lies with putin
if he's bent on continuing his uh
invasion of ukraine his campaign in
ukraine then basically it will be very
simple lavrov recites the old demands
uh basically demilitarization
recognition of the so-called donbass
republics the recognition of the crimean
annexation no nato in ukraine
kuleva says no everyone leaves
i think that if lavrov is to offer some
modified uh demands then it may be the
beginning of a kind of conversation
after two weeks of war and indeed eight
years of conflict between the two what
can be achieved at this political level
against that backdrop
a little it's only opening the doors for
for a conversation if any but i think
the important thing is that uh mevloo
the turkish foreign minister is uh
mediating uh frankly
turkey and actually specifically turkish
president reject erdogan
they belong to kind of very few entities
in the world that put in respect
uh putin respects abraham for shooting
down to russian planes for generally
treating russia is not better than
others and because of that uh i think
the turks know that they maybe can
achieve something with moscow and that
gives me a glimmer of hope that this
door will not be shot but it's a very
small glimmer frankly speaking of it
yeah the glimmer of hope it relates to
compromises what compromises could the
respective sides make starting with the
ukrainian side first
well it can only be my kind of
conjecture for now and as as well as
yours and anyone else's but i think that
one has to
proceed from the
perception that actually ukraine is
gradually winning this war
and they will not go back to any kind of
things they could discuss let's say
prior to 24th of november when putin
launched the invasion
i'd say the big bargain theoretically in
my view at least for now
will be
basically
non-nato although not neutral status of
ukraine but no no membership of nato in
exchange for complete return of
territories including the crimea i think
that is probably the minimum to which
president zielinski will agree question
is whether the russians will agree to
that and that is a very very big
yeah and then the next big and natural
question
what
uh compromises could possibly the
russians make here if any
well frankly speaking the way things go
now militarily
uh
putin has either to go really nuclear in
the literal sense of the word
or start wrapping up
this war or at least freezing
uh
i think that in current circumstances
putin will not agree to give back the
crimea i think if
he thinks that he's kind of a lifetime
achievement
but russian elite probably will be happy
to give anything away uh in order to
lift sanctions uh and i think that
um
where the russians have some kind of
leverage where the criminal has some
leverage is in the fact that zelias is a
democratically elected president who
cares for his people who cares for them
being killed maimed and basically
exiled
becoming refugees and this is a
sensitive topic which i think
uh russia will
explore and and will
try and force zelensky to
do things they want threatening more
violence against innocent ukrainians and
here of course a lot of things uh depend
on the west and on the uh on the public
support that zelensky may get or can get
from the ukrainian people as of now it
seems to be very very strong and he's
really a kind of warchief and this gives
him very very strong cards to play it
only seems that he's weakened by this
invasion i think he's been strengthened
by that
a fascinating day coming up in turkey
thank you dw political analyst
constantine eggett many thanks